a full trailer of the game actually  leaked all the way back in 2018 when  reddit user vape this bro posted it  online he claimed to have been part of a  mall survey group that was shown a  trailer for the game and he somehow  managed to get by without signing an nda  the leaked footage showed what appeared  to be a dark mature wizarding world game  with one particular scene that showed a  group of goblins meeting a rather  gruesome fate specific spells were also  shown in that trailer including lumos  alohomora repairo stupefy expulso and  depulso it's also worth noting that even  though it's pretty clear this was a  legit leak it still doesn't mean we'll  actually see all of those items in the  final game hogwarts legacy was finally  announced in an official capacity with a  trailer at the ps5 showcase event back  in september of 2020. the game was  originally slated for a 2021 release  date but has since been delayed to the  ever nebulous 2022